robert orlando brother what is up
hey john uh thanks for having me on
thank you thank you good man for calling
how can i help
so uh my wife and i are
looking at adopting my
nephews but there's a bigger
complication
in um the first word that popped in my
head when you said we're thinking of
adopting nephews i just thought
that's complicated so unwind it for us
man all right
so my it's technically my cousins but
they
are my great aunt who is in her 70s
adopted two young boys uh are
seven and five and there was some
very serious family issues uh with the
kids before she adopted them who's their
parents who's their parents
uh they are both out of the picture uh
one
mother died the father isn't there oh so
so this
your 70 year old great aunt wasn't
picking up like
two kids that were in the family she
just went out and adopted two kids on
her own
oh no no they were in they were in her
family but there was drug issues
there were okay all right i'm just
making sure that she didn't just get
like emotional one day and watch the
right video
and just decide you know oh no no no get
myself two toddlers or two young kids
okay okay no no so she did a really
noble thing which is
she stepped in in a gap of someone in
the family who wasn't living up to their
their parents responsibility she picked
up a five-year-old and uh how old you
say
five and a seven-year-old five and a
seven seven yeah well
she's had them since they were babies
right in her house since they were
babies and then because of
other issues in the family she just
adopted them
okay um so she's a gangster right she's
awesome oh she is amazing
right what a stunt what a she's amazing
uh but you know her being in that age
she her health is starting to decline
her
uh you know there are some issues
uh so i am my wife and i
have been discussing with her for the
last
i don't know four or five years uh that
when and if something happens
we would gladly begin the process of
taking in the boys
and start introducing them into our
family because we are probably the best
option
okay uh however she has
a live-in helper
now who was also part of this situation
in that she was the
girlfriend of her son of my aunt's son
right and so now her son is no longer in
the picture so do this for me robert
we are quickly turning into the jerry
springer podcast so let's like
zero it in for me you guys are going to
get these or one i picked up these two
right beautiful pick up these two kids
okay but
we're worried that the current
long time keeper is
is introducing some new
creation or whispering in her ear that
she would be the better option but we're
worried because she doesn't have
any jobs she doesn't have any long-term
goals it doesn't even look like she has
a
driver's license at the moment and so
we're we're a little worried about that
side of it so have you
have you are you and your wife if your
if your great aunt came and said today
we're ready i'm ready to pull the
trigger would you all be ready to take
them today
100 we've even got a bedroom ready have
you all done the home study and you're
all ready to rock and roll
i guess we haven't we haven't completed
the home study but we've
started the process okay all right so
the second option is
i mean the second thing is when's the
last time you sat down
seriously and said we're ready uh
well we tried to on sunday okay tell me
about that conversation
okay so so that conversation was uh
we sat down with her we said hey
we want to start looking at our
long-term
options here because we're also in a in
you know financial position to possibly
start buying a house and all of that
and we want to know what the best
options are going to be for us and then
that's when she told us hey the the
this person is actually going to be the
one that's probably going to take in the
boys
okay so
here's the hard news there if that's
what the legal guardian wants to do with
those boys that's what's going to happen
right that's heartbreaking and hard and
you guys can go to court and try to sue
over it and try to get an attorney that
will
disparage and blow up the care givers
you know the home caregivers life and
all that
or you and your wife can
begin the painful harsh process of
grieving the loss of what you thought
the future picture of your life was
going to look like and start reimagining
it or if this person is a chump
right this caregiver is like you said
it's got no jobs got no
driver's license has no ambition just
wants power just wants to take these two
kids as though they're
pets um then it's just going to delay
your
the they're moving to your house anyway
at some point
right um but it doesn't sound like you
guys have a lot of leverage
other than to deal with you the
heartbreak that's going to be inside
your house
do you feel pretty committed that your
great aunt has just has made this
decision and it's over
um i don't know
the the like i said the
her well her health has declined and i
think she's just
trying to move forward as quickly as
possible in the
event of an emergency okay so so tell me
this
do you want those kids to live with you
absolutely do you want to be the parent
of those kids
absolutely okay so this morning
i've got i've got a number of friends
and it's a heartbreaking season
covett has just done a number on
relationships across the country i've
got a number of friends whose marriages
are they found their marriages in wacky
rocky places
and i was talking to one particular
friend this morning and
she was walking me through a series of
situations that she's
stuck in right now and i told her
you must go fight for your kids
and i want to encourage you the best you
can and when i say fight don't go be
ridiculous and don't go be immature
fighting for you in this situation is
setting up a dinner this week with your
great aunt
either go to her house if she's not
mobile or
invite her off site get her out of the
house out of the picture
and tell her hey i'm uncomfortable with
the conversation we had on sunday
my wife and i are ready to buy a house
we have started the home study process
we've been in those boys lives and we
want to in no uncertain terms we want to
adopt
those kids we want them to be ours we
want them to move to our home you've
done an extraordinary heroic job
getting them from being a taller to now
and we are ready to take over
and we'd love to have you come over all
the time and still be super involved in
their life as long as your health can
handle that
but i think at this point you got to be
aggressive and go out and say this is
what i want and then
put her on the spot and say no i've
chosen somebody else
okay and then does that make sense and
then you and your wife get some clarity
and then you all know and again i'm not
going to discourage you from going to
get a lawyer if you think this other
person's bad and the kids are going to
be in bad shape or bad health
go do what you need to do if you think
that's more
you looking in the mirror and saying i
would be better than this person
then that's your own baggage that you
got to deal with right right
um but at the end of the day i want you
to go fight for your kids if that's who
you if you i mean if you think they're
your kids and
you are setting up a home for those kids
then go fight for them go tell your
great aunt nope i don't like how that
conversation went their hours
i want them to be ours we're ready to
adopt ready to pull the trigger right
now
okay how does that sound yes
i i yeah that that does give me
at least at least something that will
give me some more clarity
so that's that's what i need is is to
know yes or no and then like you said
if i need to grieve but that's not what
our our life is going to take us and i
need to grieve that
okay and here's the deal grieving is
going to look like this
grieving is going to look like you and
your wife and probably some close
friends
maybe some people from your church maybe
some people from your softball league
and that's you coming over to your house
inviting them over and you all have a
ceremony
a small miniature get-together that says
a collective funeral a collective
grieving moment for
what wasn't having a ceremony
is so important to mark something a
moment
of our life was going one way and it is
now suddenly going another way
and having those markers there puts a
time stamp in it puts a flag in the
ground
and it becomes an important touchstone
down the road when you can remember this
is the moment when we said
regardless what happened life's going
left life's going right and we thought
it was going straight
and it just gives you this tether too
then you can begin the
painful awful struggle of planning on
what's gonna
what tomorrow's gonna bring right do you
go back to the adoption agency
um do you have biological kids whatever
whatever your story is gonna unfold down
the road right
but it gives you a touchdown moment so
make sure when you agree this you grieve
it with a
a ceremony and then you're probably
going to get somebody to walk alongside
you and your wife as you all transition
from one thing to another but i honestly
don't want to go there yet robert i want
you to go have that conversation with
your great aunt i want you to look in
the eye and say those are my kids
we want them to be ours we are ready to
pull the trigger right now and we want
you to be a part of their life even
though they're going to start
transitioning and moving in with us
and put her on the spot and see what she
says she may just surprise you
okay so thanks for the call robert